madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois chers collègues 10
semaines après l'adoption à l'unanimité
de la proposition de loi de Céline
Brulin et ses collègues du Congo
communiste républicain citoyen
écologique nous examinons un nouveau
texte visant à revaloriser le métier de
secrétaire de mairie déposer cette
fois-ci par Monsieur François Patriat
ses collègues du groupe rassemblement
démocrate progressistes et indépendant
et des collègues d'autres groupes les
textes se suivent et ne se ressemblent
pas toutefois et contrairement à la
proposition de loi précédente le
gouvernement a engagé la procédure
accélérée le 1er juin
nous pouvons sans aucun doute y voir le
signe de sa volonté que ce texte
aboutisse bien évidemment nous saluons
ce volontarisme même si nous déplorons
également qui n'en soit pas allés de
même sur la proposition de loi du groupe
CRCE que je remercie une fois encore
d'avoir initié le processus de réflexion
et d'action sur cette problématique
quoi qu'il en soit l'essentiel est que
des mesures concrètes soient rapidement
prises pour répondre aux besoins
légitimes de reconnaissance des agents
qui exercent les fonctions de secrétaire
de mairie et remédier au manque
d'attractivité dans ce métier souffrent
aujourd'hui sans quoi la pénurie de
secrétaire de mairie à laquelle font
face aujourd'hui la quasi totalité des
maires des communes de moins de 2000
habitants ne pourra que s'aggraver et
une fine ce sera le bon fonctionnement
de ces communes qui sera compromis et la
qualité du service public qui en pâtira
la commission des lois partage donc
pleinement la visée de la prison
proposition de loi de revaloriser le
métier de secrétaire de mairie elle
souscrit en particulier à l'objectif de
favoriser l'accès à la catégorie B pour
des agents qui parmi les secrétaires de
mairie relève de la catégorie C la
proposition de loi en tant favorisé cet
accès par le biais de deux nouvelles
voies de promotion interne la première
dérogeant à la règle des quotas
expirerait au 31 décembre 2028 tandis
que la deuxième reposant sur la validité
d'une formation qualifiante serait
pérenne
c'est une évidence il est grand temps de
mettre en adéquation les compétences
multiples et exigeantes qui sont
attendues des secrétaires de mairie et
les responsabilités importantes qui leur
sont confiées avec le niveau de
catégorie hiérarchique reconnue en
conséquence il convient de consacrer
l'emploi de secrétaire numérique comme
un emploi de catégorie B au moins
j'insiste vraiment monsieur le ministre
sur ce sujet pour ce faire la priorité
est de mettre de permettre aux agents de
catégorie C qui sont aujourd'hui en
poste d'accéder à la catégorie B qui
sera déterminée par décret en pratique
se réviser des secrétaires de mairie de
catégorie ceux qui ont qui sont en poste
depuis 15 20 ou 25 ans qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de passer les concours et à
qui les règles de la promotion interne
de droit commun ne permettent pas non
plus de passer en catégorie B un délai
d'environ cinq ans leur serait offert
pour bénéficier de cette voie des
rogatoire de promotion interne c'est
donc l'objectif de l'article premier
dans sa rédaction
issue des travaux de la commission
la deuxième étape est de permettre aux
agents de catégoriser en poste depuis
une durée moindre d'accéder également à
la catégorie B à la condition cette
fois-ci d'avoir validé une formation
qualifiante cette nouvelle loi de
promotion interne est proposée par
l'article 2 tel que modifié par la
Commission
en commission nous avions jugé
nécessaire de lever l’ambiguïté qui
affectait la rédaction de l'article 2 et
avions donc réservé au secrétaire mairie
déjà en poste la voie de la promotion
interne par la formation qualifiante
notre objectif était de ne pas accroître
pour l'avenir le nombre de secrétaires
de mairie de catégorie C cela nous
semblait en contradiction avec la
conduction selon laquelle l'emploi de
secrétaire de mairie doit être réservé
aux catégories B et A la rédaction
proposée par le gouvernement à l'article
2 nous sont toutefois adéquates en
permettant aux agents qui seraient
nommés à un emploi de secrétaire de
mairie entre la promulgation de la loi
et le 31 décembre 2028 de bénéficier de
la promotion interne via la formation
qualifiante cette date du 31 décembre
2028 est importante elle doit marquer
selon nous la fin de la possibilité pour
les maires de nommer aux emplois de
secrétaire de mairie un agent de
catégorie C débutera ainsi une nouvelle
dynamique de recrutement et pour les
secrétaires de mairie la consécration
pleine et entière de leur emploi comme
un emploi de catégorie B bien évidemment
ce tournant fondamental nécessitera une
mesure réglementaire à savoir la
modification du statut particulier du
cadre d'emploi des adjoints
administratifs territoriaux nous serons
pas conséquent particulièrement
attentifs à ce que le gouvernement
procède à cette modification sans elle
la présence proposition de loi manquera
son objectif essentiel par ailleurs la
Commission a souhaité renforcer
l'identification des fonctions de
secrétaire de mairie et pour cela
consacrer de manière innovante
l'exercice de telles fonctions dans le
Code Général des Collectivités
Territoriales cette disposition pourra
je le crois contribuent à la meilleure
reconnaissance de ses agents en levant
les ambiguïtés qui peuvent exister
aujourd'hui
enfin nous devons enfin nous devons
tirer parti de la succession à quelques
semaines d'intervalle de deux textes
pourtant sur le même sujet pour enrichir
le texte que nous dont nous discutons
aujourd'hui par les dispositions votées
à l'unanimité en avril
afin d'accroître l'ambition de la
présence proposition de loi la
Commission a donc repris les mesures
relatives à la formation à la promotion
interne et à l'emploi de contractuel
tout d'abord la Commission a souhaité
conforter la formation des secrétaires
de mairie qui est essentiel au regard de
la variété des missions exercées de la
technicité des compétences requises
l'article 2 bis introduit ainsi une
formation initiale obligatoire propre à
ces agents
l'objectif est que chaque secrétaire
mérite dispose dès sa prise de poste des
outils adaptés pour exercer ces missions
nous savons en effet combien une fois en
poste il devient difficile au secrétaire
de mairie de suivre des formations même
de quelques jours seulement par manque
de temps éloignement géographique du
lieu de formation et surtout en raison
de la quasi impossibilité à se faire
remplacer en leur absence
ensuite parce qu'il est nécessaire
d'améliorer les perspectives d'évolution
de carrière de l'ensemble des
secrétaires américains quel que soit
leur cadre d'emploi l'article de terre
vise à favoriser de façon pérenne aussi
bien la promotion interne des
secrétaires de mairie de catégorie C
pour leur accès à la catégorie B que
celle des secrétaires de mairie de
catégorie B pour leur accès à la
catégorie A il nous semble en effet
important de ne pas oublier des agents
de catégories B qui exercent aussi
depuis de nombreuses années et qui n'ont
pas la possibilité de passer un concours
pour accéder à la catégorie enfin la
commission a jugé nécessaire de
compléter les dispositions visant à
renforcer l'attractivité de l'emploi de
secrétaire de mairie par une mesure
visant à donner aux employeurs locaux
davantage de souplesse ainsi l'article 4
permet aux communes contentes entre 1000
et 2000 habitants
le recruter des agents contractuels
attend complet aux emplois de secrétaire
de mairie sachant qu'aujourd'hui elles
peuvent déjà le faire pour des emplois à
temps non complets donc la commission
des Lois vous propose d'atopter cette
proposition de loi ainsi modifier alors
nous reconnaissons tous qu'elles ne
pourra pas remédier à elle seule au
manque d'attractivité dans souffre ce
métier ni répondre aux besoins criant de
reconnaissance de milieu d'agent de
milliers d'agents je suis néanmoins
convaincue qu'en faisant de l'emploi du
secrétaire de mairie un emploi de
catégorie B nous enverrons un signal
fort à la fois aux agents et aux maires
et que nous amorcerons une véritable
revalorisation de ce métier
indispensable à nos communes et à nos
concitoyens
chers collègues à deux mois d'écart le
Sénat a pris ce sujet à bras le corps
j'espère qu'il s'exprimera tout à
l'heure avec la même belle unanimité que
le 6 avril dernier il revient désormais
au gouvernement non seulement de veiller
à ce que ce texte acquiert force de loi
mais également de travailler sans plus
attendre à ses évolutions concrètes pour
ce faire il pourra s'appuyer sur le
travail réalisé par les rapporteurs de
la mission d'information sur
l'attractivité du métier de secrétaire
de mairie initié par la délégation
collectivité territoriale
avec mes collègues Cédric Vial Jérôme
Durin nous avons formulé un certain
nombre de propositions très précises qui
relèvent du domaine réglementaire
certaines pouvant être mises en
application sans trop tarder d'autres de
nature législatives seront présentées
par amendement tout à l'heure
au-delà de la question relative à la
catégorie hiérarchique à la formation ce
sont les règles relatives à la
rémunération des secrétaires américains
qui doivent être revus plus largement
c'est l'ensemble des grilles indiciaires
de la fonction publique territoriale qui
doit être réformée la récente
revalorisation de l'indice minimum de
traitement pour suivre l'augmentation du
SMIC à en effet accru encore un peu plus
le tassement des grilles indiciaires un
tiers des agents des collectivités et
désormais payé au smic de même la
refonte générale des règles d'avancement
pour l'ensemble des fonctionnaires
mériteraient d'être menées à bien au
plus vite alors monsieur le ministre je
vous le disais déjà le 6 avril la balle
est dans votre camp et merci de ne pas
attendre un troisième texte pour agir je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
chers collègues